PROFESSOR: OK.
So how do we find
these stable marriages?
Well there's out
procedure for doing it,
which is kind of elegantly
described as a day
by day mating ritual that the
boys and girls cooperate in.
So let's see what
happens on the first day.
On the morning of the
first day, each boy
looks at his list
of girls and picks
the one that he likes the
best, at the top of this list,
and he goes off and serenades
her or proposes to her.
So here we have Billy Bob and
Brad proposing to Angelina.
That means that on
the first day Angelina
was at the top of both Brad's
list and Billy Bob's list.
And they're both going to
be proposing and asking
if she's willing to marry them.
Well in the afternoon,
each girl rejects all but
her favorite suitor.
So in this case, Angelina
likes Brad best of all.
So she says to everybody else,
if you're not Brad take a hike.
And that's what
happens at that stage.
And then in the
evening, here we look
at rejected boy, Billy Bob.
A boy who's rejected crosses
off the girl who rejected him.
So Billy Bob is going to
cross Angelina off his list.
And then the whole
ritual is going
to repeat starting
the next morning.
Except now Billy Bob will
have a different woman
at the top of his list because
Angelina's gone forever.
This mating ritual continues
until nothing changes.
And that's going to happen
exactly when each girl has
at most one suitor.
Because if she has
more than one suitor,
she's going to reject
the less favorite ones.
So that is the definition
of the stopping condition.
And on that day, by
definition, no girl
can have more than one suitor.
So she will marry the
one suitor she has.
And that's the definition of
the marriages that result,
if and when, the
mating ritual stops.
And we claim that they are
going to be stable marriages.
Now if we think
about this process,
it's really a state machine.
In fact, if you think about
it, what the states are
is the set of girls on the
boys list on any given morning.
And then those states
evolve to a new list
after the crossing out
happens on the next morning.
So this is kind
of a memorable way
to tell a story about the
transitions of a state machine.
And we can bring our state
machine concepts to bear.
So the first thing
we want to prove
is that this state
machine terminates.
That is to say, there
exists a wedding day.
Then we want to
prove that this state
machine is partially correct.
And what that means that
when the machine stops,
everyone is married and that
the marriages are stable.
So that's our task.
Well termination's easy.
Because if you
look at the state,
the state is the boys
lists on a given morning.
And things evolve
because boys get rejected
and they cross
girls off the list.
So what that means, if we
take the total number of names
remaining on the boys lists
on any given morning, that
is a strictly decreasing and
non-negative integer valued
variable.
So by the well-ordering
principle,
that's strictly decreasing.
Well-ordered derived variable
will reach a minimum value.
And by definition,
that's when the algorithm
has to stop because it's
strictly increasing.
So it can't move once
it's reached its minimum.
So there's a wedding day.
All right.
So now let's examine
correctness of this procedure
and figure out what's supposed
to happen on the wedding day.
We want to show that
everybody's married
and that the
marriages are stable.
And in order to do
that, we're going
to look at some more derived
variables and an invariant that
explains why the
mating ritual works.
So the first remark is that
the girls improve day by day,
or at least they
don't get any worse.
Namely, a girl's
favorite tomorrow
will be at least as desirable
to her as her favorite today.
That's for any given day.
If you look at a girl's
favorite on this day,
and if there is a tomorrow,
then her favorite tomorrow
is going to be at least as
good as the one she has.
And why is that?
Well because today's favorite
will keep serenading her
until he gets rejected.
And he only gets rejected when
the girl that he's serenading
gets yet a better suitor.
And so the girls are
always going to improve.
We could reformulate this
in state machine language
by saying that the rank
of a girl's favorite,
where she rates the boy
that's serenading her
on her own list of preferences,
is a weekly increasing
variable.
It never gets any worse
from one day to the next.
By the same reasoning
or similar reasoning,
a boy's favorite tomorrow is
going to be no better than
today's.
It might be worse.
And so it's no more-- the
woman that he's going to say,
tomorrow is no more desirable to
him than today's, is basically
because he works
straight down his list.
If he hasn't been
rejected, he'll
keep serenading the
same woman tomorrow.
If he has been
rejected, then he's
going to be working
on somebody lower
on his list that's
less desirable.
So again, the rank of a girl
on a boy, that a boy serenades,
is a weekly decreasing derived
variable of this process.
And these observations lead
us to an invariant that
holds for the mating ritual.
And the invariant is that
if you look at any girl G,
and if there's a
boy B and G is not
on B's list, that is G
must've been crossed off
by B at some point, then the
invariant is that the girl
G has a favorite that
is better than B.
And the reason is that
again, when G rejected B,
she had a better suitor
than B. And her suitors keep
getting better by
the weekly increasing
property of her suitors.
And therefore,
she's going to have
a suitor that she likes better
than B, whose list she's not
on.
This holds for all G's and B's.
And that is an invariant
from one day to the next.
So let's look at what
happens on the wedding day
and use the invariant to
prove that everybody's married
and that stability holds.
So the first remark is that each
girl has at most one suitor,
and we've observed that's by
definition of a wedding day.
And now what we want to prove
is that each boy gets married.
Well what's going on with a
boy, a boy is either married
because he's serenading
the top woman on his list,
or maybe all the women on his
list have been crossed off,
then he's not
serenading anybody.
So that's the only way
he could be not married.
Now the reason that
this is the case
is that there's no bigamy here.
So boys serenade only
one girl at a time.
So if a boy is married,
there's only one possible woman
that he can be married to.
And a woman's married
to one possible boy.
So let's now put these
facts together and argue
that everybody is married
on the wedding day.
And the proof is
by contradiction.
Suppose there's some boy
B that's not married.
Well that happens exactly
when his list is empty.
Otherwise, he'd be serenading
somebody and be married to her.
But if his list is
empty by the invariant,
every girl has a
suitor that she likes
better than B, which means she's
going to be married to somebody
that she likes better than B.
Every girl's married.
But there are the same
number of boys and girls.
So in fact, given that
there's no bigamy,
all the boys have
to be married too.
And that settles that one.
So the next crucial property
that we're interested in
is stability.
That in fact this
set of marriages,
which must come into
being on the wedding day,
are all stable.
And the argument for
stability has two cases,
both of them trivial that follow
immediately from the invariant.
First of all, let's look
at an arbitrary boy, Bob.
I claim that he won't
be in a rogue couple
with case one, any girl G
that's on his final list.
Because if a girl is
on his final list,
then he's already married
to the best of them.
He marries the girl at
the top of his list.
So he's not going to
be tempted to switch--
to be part of a rogue couple
with some girl that's still
on his list.
Case two is, he's not going
to be in a rogue couple
with a girl that's
not on his list.
Because, by the invariant,
she's married to somebody
she likes better than him.
So there's no available
girl either way for Bob
to be in a rogue couple with.
Bob, of course, is
an arbitrary boy.
And therefore, no boy
is in a rogue couple.
And indeed, there
are no rogue couples.